sono una video patricio di persone
infatti io mi occupo di aiutare le
persone a capire qual è il loro
potenziale e ha sviluppato il meglio per
svolgere le loro attività quotidiana
questo lavoro mi porta essere spesso
presente in aula con le persone è una
delle cose che mi piace di più quando
iniziò una formazione di raccontare una
storia perché le storie sono belle
perché le storie sono la nostra infanzia
e ci permette di mettersi molto
direttamente in contatto con il
contenuto della formazione quindi oggi
favo questo il racconto con una storia
la storia del muscolo più bello il
muscolo della resilienza perché mi piace
definirlo un muscolo
molto semplicemente perché la resilienza
si può allenare ogni volta che ci
troviamo in una situazione di difficoltà
e grazie a questo muscolo che riusciamo
a trovare la soluzione migliore ea
uscire del problema la piccola si voi
fate la domanda la mia maestra della
scuola elementare sicuramente levi
avrebbe detto che io non avrei mai
potuto raggiungere la mia allora perché
di formazione effettivamente sono
giornalista perché questo perché mi è
stato diagnosticato molto velocemente
una fortissima dislessia
questa situazione mi portavo che durante
le elezioni quando c'erano i momenti di
dettato il momento di lettura ad alta
voce mi sentivo sprofondata mi sentivo
molto sola mi sentivo giudicata dai miei
compagni e soprattutto non apprezzato
per il mio valore
dalla mia maestra che comunque per lei
al di là di tutto quello che avrei
potuto fare
rimanevo dislessica oggi sono
responsabili della formazione e dello
sviluppo per una grande multinazionale
una multinazionale che ha una missione
molto bello
la missione è di dare bellezza a tutti
gli uomini e le donne nel rispetto della
loro diversità una missione sicuramente
molto l'ambizione ambiziose ma anche una
uno slogan molto forte infatti penso che
tutti quanti avete capito di chi stiamo
parlando
è un'azienda che ha fatto dire a tutte
le donne più belle del mondo perché io
valgo perché io valgo però non impedisce
allora e al di non essere oggi toccato
dalla crisi economica che esiste
soprattutto in italia l'italia è un
paese che veramente molto toccato da
questa crisi e anche noi la sentiamo
però per una multinazionale è difficile
quando ci sia leader del mercato di
rimettersi in gioco di cambiare le
modalità che abbiamo utilizzato per anni
e che ci hanno sempre portato al
successo quindi diventa difficile di
cambiare quindi che cosa abbiamo fatto
abbiamo preso del tempo ci siamo fermati
e abbiamo cercato di capire il contesto
che stava intorno a noi
in che contesto siamo oggi c'è una
parola nella letteratura che definisce
questo contesto che a noi al real ci
piace molto utilizzare diciamo che
viviamo in un contesto buca buca quindi
un acronimo di qua tre parole volatility
danzatrici complessi ti ambiguity che
cercherò di spiegarvi rapidamente la
volatilità noi la vediamo tutti i giorni
nel giornale
e si tratta del totale imprevedibilità
dei mercati della borsa oggi lo vediamo
tutti i giorni questa situazione inserto
in tv l'incertezza penso che tutti noi
abbiamo delle persone intorno a noi un
figlio piuttosto che con un amico che
non riesce a in carne o a rientrare nel
mondo del lavoro perché il mondo del
lavoro è incerto perché il mondo del
lavoro è precario oggi la terza parola e
la complessità la complessità è dovuto
al mondo che oggi vi do un esempio molto
semplice si ieri si potevano spostare in
città utilizzando oi mezzi pubblici o ai
mezzi privati
oggi non è più così oggi abbiamo una
moltitudine di possibilità che vanno dal
bike sharing a bla bla kat
e tutta questa moltitudine di scelta
rende la situazione molto più complesso
per noi l'ambiguita l'ultima parola è la
conseguenza di tutto il resto che fa che
qualsiasi situazione
qualsiasi soluzione prendiamo siamo
sempre nell'incertezza di essere sicuro
e che è stato la soluzione giusta
quindi siamo sempre in questa sensazione
di ambiguità di non avere preso la
decisione giusta quindi fatta questa
defezione sul contesto con i miei
superiori ci siamo detti ok il contesto
non si può cambiare
lo dobbiamo prendere con me quindi come
possiamo noi e come possiamo aiutare le
persone ad essere più forti in un
contesto così a sentirsi meno debole
avere energia a riuscire a portare
avanti gli obiettivi che hanno e quindi
siamo ha detto c'è una competenza è
molto forte che è la resilienza
vediamo di allenare nostro persona la
resilienza
mi avete molto semplice sono
responsabili della formazione quindi
ovviamente tocca a me di fare questa
cosa come si sa
spessissimo incontri più occasionale
sono gli incontri più fortunati e io ho
avuto la fortuna qualche anni fa di
incontrare l'arte nel cuore
l'arte nel cuore è una bellissima realtà
che ho scoperto così per caso
stavo andando a parigi il sento nel
notizia l'enel taxi questa notizia che
dici questa sera l'oreal apre le sue
porte all'academia l'arte nel cuore
un'accademia molto diversa ovviamente
questa notizia mi sorprende perché ero
totalmente lo sconosciuto di questa cosa
rientro in italia e mi informo su questa
accademia scopo che effettivamente
l'arte nel cuore e un'accademia che si
trova a roma che permetterà dei ragazzi
normodotati e disabili di poter
riformarsi ai mestiere del mondo dello
spettacolo
questa accademia offre a queste ragazzi
tantissimi corsi che vanno dalla
recitazione al canto per arrivare al
trucco e parrucco ed è lì che l'oreal si
inserisce con loro aiutandole
sponsorizzando le per la realizzazione
di questi due corsi mi informo e chiamò
la fondatrice di questa bellissima
realtà che si chiama daniela l'hair cut
so che è una donna molto forte molto
decise e mi dice al telefono guardi mi
venga a trovare a roma
due settimane dopo arrivò roma un contro
daniela e subito mi porta davanti una
porta dove scritte sali di recitazione e
mi dici guardi daniele secondo me è il
modo migliore per capire che cosa
facciamo qua all'arte nel cuore e di
andare in classi con i ragazzi ed è
partecipare a una lezione
ok entro vado a vedere che cosa rischio
e quindi entro in questa classe davanti
a me mi ritrovo 15 ragazzi disabili e
normodotati un insegnante che ha più di
80 anni che arriva verso di me con una
grandissima empatia e mi dici wavi
daniela stavamo aspettando le e qua con
noi oggi il nostro obiettivo della
lezione di leggere per la prima volta il
copione del nuovo spettacolo che andremo
a fine anno
lei doveva deve fare la parte di valeria
e si vada a sedere vicina a lulu e a
tiziano in un momento mi sono ritrovato
proiettata nella scuola elementare con
questo copione in mano in un contesto da
me totalmente sconosciuto con vicina a
me
lulu e tiziano è veramente ho vissuto un
fortissimo buca a quel momento lì ho
fatto veramente fatica mi sono seduto
vicino a loro devo nel giro di poco e
istante non ho risentito le stesse cose
che sentivo quando ero alla scuola
alimentare questo senso di solitudine di
sicurezza di incapacità di raggiungere
l'obiettivo
mi sono sentita aiutata dalle due
persone che erano con me mi sono sentito
guidata da questa insegnante insaziabile
nella convinzione che avrebbe potuto
recitare la parte di valeria senza
accento era una cosa veramente magica
abbiamo finito la lezione abbiamo
raggiunto il mio obiettivo
avevamo letto effettivamente il copione
ed eravamo tutti molto molto felice
c'era un energia veramente palpava
fra di noi rientro a milano sempre con
il compito di dovere allenare tutte le
persone del real alla resilienza e lì in
un colpo mi rendo conto mi è tutto
chiaro quello che avevo vissuto a roma
con l'arte nel cuore era stata
un'esperienza di fortissimo resilienza e
ne era uscita molto bene quindi che cosa
non mi sono detto dobbiamo fare la
stessa cosa
li ho chiesto l'aiuto di massimiliano
che è un coach che ti accompagna la
nostra attività di formazione e abbiamo
sviluppato due attività la prima
attività è un'attività più di
sensibilizzazione che è aperta a tutti i
collaboratori del real e abbiamo chiesto
a l'arte nel cuore di venire a fare una
presentazione da noi a milano durante
questa rappresentazione che potete
vedere dall'immagine qui dietro di me
durante questa rappresentazione siamo
stati trascinati dai ragazzi disabili e
normodotati che hanno fatto questa
rappresentazione molto dinamica molto
molto divertente e che sono veramente
riuscita alla fine di questa
rappresentazione a renderci conto che
nel momento in cui abbiamo un obiettivo
comune e che avrà ville vogliamo tutti
raggiungere questo obiettivo
non ci sono tanti limiti che ci si
possono fermare a raggiungerli e
possiamo veramente a raggiungere un
obiettivo perfetto la seconda attività è
un'attività più dove andiamo allenare i
nostri collaboratori quindi che cosa
facciamo
su queste due giornate che fanno di
formazioni con noi nella prima giornata
le portiamo a roma e le facciamo vivere
esattamente le esperienze che ho vissuto
la prima volta che sono andata l'arte
nel cuore e poi la giornata successivo
con massimiliano le aiutiamo a
decodificare l'esperienza di resilienza
che hanno avuto
e a farle vivere quali sono le loro
proprie esperienze di resilienza
però lì vi lascio alle immagini e ai
commenti dei collaboratori dell'ora et
al
è stato veramente divertente
innanzitutto e abbiamo imparato molto da
loro
emozionante liberatorio coinvolgente
nonostante all'inizio ci fosse magari un
po di disagio perché non sono abituati a
farlo
e bello vedere anche come gli scambi fra
persone credono
la ricchezza
fini o così c'è la cosa interessante
anche di questo progetto con l'arte nel
cuore e che c'è una grande innovazione
nella tipologia di relazioni che abbiamo
oggi con l'arte nel cuore di fatti prima
eravamo per loro delle persone che lo
aiutavano con delle sponsorizzazioni che
un della carità oggi quando ci troviamo
in nola con i ragazzi dell'arte nel
cuore sono loro che diventano il nostro
insegnante
sono loro che ci aiutano a capire che
cosa vuoi dire la resilienza e quando
facciamo queste attività con loro c'è
una cosa che esce veramente molto molto
forte e lo slogan perché noi vogliamo a
questo momento qua non è mai stato così
autentico cazzi